michael tu vas bien j'ai mis le doigt
sur du lot l'ensemble du marché
immobilier recrues furent des prêts
irrécouvrables
ils vont dans le mur le marché de
l'immobilier est en béton c'est une
bombe à retardement
mike beurre et qui se coupe les cheveux
au sécateur et qui marche pieds nus sera
mieux informés qu alan greenspan docteur
marc bury je confirme oui ça me met hors
de moi et c'est là que ce type arrivent
dans nos bureaux et balance il ya comme
une grosse arnaque dans l'air les
banques font couler le champagne à flots
seule une poignée d' outsider affaires
et cours économie mondiale pourrait
s'effondrer
les bons coups et evora c
et là on va leur faire mal tu veut miser
contre une banque ils penseront qu'on a
pu mais au fait un avc
ça me plaît
je suis sûr que les banques mondiales
ont d'autres motivations de la cupidité
vous avez tort
laurent p touché la grèce et l'islande
sont à terre l'espagne bat 6
si vous vous trompez vous êtes mort
alors c'est parti